up Indiana does have a timeout
115 113 Lakers Pacers get it in Turner
for the lead short tip taken Halliburton
Halliburton this is to win the game
Indiana wins it
rolling on the floor is a success
[Music]
these are the kind of games where you
look back on and you just just dread
looking at this tape
you had the game under control and then
all of a sudden you relaxed it as a
result
you lose at the buzzer on a
three-pointer Andrew Dem hard
[Applause]
the Lakers forced the first Miss but
could not get the rebound
and as a result you're out of position
defensively
ball tipped around and look nobody's
matching up there's people there you got
to match up to people
give credit to Halliburton who found him
that was the fourth made three by
nebhart tonight and for Halliburton his
14th assist and a heartbreaker for the
Lakers and what a gritty win for Indiana
this this is this is going to be a real
difficult appeal for the Lakers as well
yeah they were very difficult they were
up by 17 points they were up having a
good time and you got to play with the
same kind of passion for 48 minutes